thank you
welcome to the creek in the cave
a few things before we get started
please stay off your cell phones no
heckling and keep table talk to a
minimum who's ready for other people
well you know if you love them give it
up for your host it's Hans King
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is up Austin Texas United
States
North America any of these hitting for
you guys anyone relate to any of these
Geographic locations apparently not it's
great to be here we're gonna watch
people date each other and try to get
freaky with it it's gonna be fun my name
is Hans Kim one of the best daters in
Austin if I come up on your Tinder you
know it's going to be a good time she's
taking a big sip we're all having a good
time a lot of a lot of couples here
tonight they're like let's watch single
people aren't you lucky you have me
honey you'd have to be doing this show
without me just gloating
let's show these married people how we
single people do it by getting getting
it jiggy with it
oh my God you guys all hate me uh it's
good to be here uh my name is Hans Kim
just coming back from a weekend in
Atlanta opening up for the great Joe
Rogan on the Fox Theater you might have
heard of him thank you
pretty famous
I have to tell if I have to tell you I'm
famous I'm not that famous
uh but uh yeah we got a great panel of
Judges here to judge your dating uh we
got some of the best dylans in comedy
tonight some of the funniest funniest
comedians in Austin please get out for
Dylan Sullivan from lights out with
David Spade and Dylan jarbo from
Jacksonville Florida
uh
[Applause]
welcome to the show Dylan's
Dylan one Dylan two I don't know how I'm
gonna tell them apart
they look so similar we do
one of us Mike's work
one of us was on a TV show the other is
from Jacksonville Florida you'll figure
it out
I just turned it on let's do this guys
oh professional comedian Dylan gerbo
they usually keep it on who here's here
to date
five people
who here is just here to have a good
time and watch people embarrass
themselves
yeah that's most of you guys well
luckily we got this table right here
full of crazy
you guys are from Hicksville Texas
no just kidding you're just wearing
overalls I had to go with what I see
uh so we're gonna get two people to come
out of a bucket and then we're gonna
watch them date right here and then
after a minute we're gonna interview
them and find out what they're really
all about and why they did what they did
are you guys ready to watch people date
hell yeah
we're gonna pick a straight woman and a
straight man one of you guys can pick a
man I'll pick a straight female
you wanna do the man we got Blanca
Bianca Vega Blanca Vega
here we go Blanca Vega the stairs are
right over there please make your way in
an orderly fashion
and sorry about this Blanco because your
day is someone named Shadow
I'm sorry chatto
but you're gonna have to go on a date
with Blanca
[Music]
here he comes wearing his finest
leather jacket
what's up
starting now
we're starting now
hi hi we I really this is my first time
I might just you talk to her I
I'm Chuck I don't know what we're doing
I don't either it's our first time so
this is a great bucket pool
so where are you from
um North Carolina oh really yeah just
visiting Austin uh no just moved here oh
really for how long
um what how have you been here a month
oh really me too I I've been like eight
weeks okay where are you from I'm
actually from Phoenix okay
so this is Damian yeah on stage yeah
right on yeah this is going well guys
are we doing right are we should I ask
her I don't know
it nailed it
so have you done anything interesting
interesting out here since you've been
here
um have you seen the bats no I've
smelled it yeah it was a lot better yeah
that might be homeless people too though
that could be it yeah yeah there's a lot
of homeless people and bats are out here
so we're just riffing for a minute
all right
so how old are you
oh wow I'm 41. okay yeah and time give
it up for this Predator right there and
his victim please stay in your seats
we're gonna interview you a little bit
Blanca Vega you have the energy of
someone who just watched the new Jeffrey
Dahmer documentary
yeah have you seen it I
I oh yeah I could tell yeah you're kind
of kind of seem afraid of the beautiful
uh man over it what's this shadow shadow
as if Chad wasn't douchey enough he had
to add an O to the end of it
shadow that was my last name what did
you think about Chad oblanka is that am
I saying that right
yeah
you're saying my name correct okay
Blanca yeah
yeah very nice yeah yeah it's very nice
yeah he seemed like a babysitter
interview is like interviewing you for a
babysitting job that seems about what
the age appropriation was yeah
yeah thank you
wow is it hot in here or was it that
chemistry
is uh I I felt bad that we ended it
right when it was getting good they
really started to know each other yeah
yeah where uh she was like oh I've been
here for a month and he's like I've been
here for a month well eight weeks and uh
it was a month at one time it wouldn't
it may be easier for next time like say
two months that would be but it was a
month and then it became too much so
yeah I just realized it was two months
all right
hey are you are you rich chatho I am not
but thank you for noticing the uh the
outfit though yeah okay I used to be
well I wasn't gonna say you were rich
yeah
that's good to know what do you do
Shadow I own some CBD companies online
and uh oh nice I work in HR oh nice this
could work out great between the both of
you forbidden lust that's great if you
had to fire chatto how would you do it
in a public place probably like the sun
right here yeah
it'll make him watch something weird and
then he can leave
reference from the new hit show Jeffrey
Dahmer check it out on Netflix what's a
good public place to fire someone
um like a Starbucks or like a coffee
shop on Stage a creepy cave
yeah this could be a Starbucks
eventually one day what Starbucks would
you go to
one where there's like heavy police
presence usually
so a lot of security
shadow looks like you could get violent
you know
it's got a taser on it but in like a
controlled
way over like a school shooter yeah yeah
yeah with the shadow what's the most
violent thing that you've done so far in
your life
wow I uh
I went to a rival CBD company and told
him stop putting flyers on my cars and
they called the cops and I had to go to
anger management for that
damn yeah it's real I have a CBD
business yeah it gets tough out there
it's almost as Poe and as real weed yeah
I got a little gangster on them hey
Blanco you ever dated a bad boy
he's a bad boy of CBD
what kind of beer do you drink O'Doul's
no I uh I'm a whiskey guy
hell yeah what about you Blanca I can't
drink beer I'm gluten I can't do gluten
holy [ __ ] Welcome to Austin you fit
right in
yeah you guys have something in common
we can talk about that after gluten yeah
you can tell by this the way I looked I
have a gluten allergy what the [ __ ] is
that well no also that that you saw me
in the bathroom no I did not
white people can sense this in each
other it's just the white
anyways Blanca what race are you
not white hell yeah that's what we like
to hear
[Laughter]
you actually now own own shadow he's
your slave
just kidding Shadow uh how's your life
been what's the best thing that's
happened to you since you've been White
since I've been white well I grew up in
Gary Indiana so that was not a privilege
of uh why see some people know people
hate Gary there's no Gary Indiana really
it's like it's like a brick house left
um then I uh I don't know man the best
thing about uh my life so far is come
down to Austin actually beat some great
comics and getting some stations so your
life was [ __ ] two months ago it really
was yeah yeah it was like since you
moved here you've been smelling bats and
yeah I've been just living in my van
down by a river no hell yeah he's a work
in progress really that was also that
was also a line I like by you Shadow you
were like hey don't homeless people
smell
yeah see I've been lost it too much I
know you hit her with the left and then
you hit her with the right yeah that's
good oh it's great to bring up the less
fortunate on a date
Blanca are you here with your boyfriend
he seems to be filming you right now oh
no that's my roommate oh hell yeah
roommate a roommate yeah
that that sucks man
I would hate to be roommates with a hot
girl uh you know this being live
streamed so just just in case you want
to know uh sorry that I read out your
whole name uh I won't say it again but
don't rewind if you're watching
don't stalk anyone uh Blanca how did you
meet your roommate
a mutual friend from nice yeah
before I moved here okay so you guys
moved here together yeah he's also from
North Carolina
I don't know anything about him no I
don't
know
what's his social security number I
don't know that I don't know that
shadow how is Phoenix you go to the
university there it was good uh no I
didn't go to the university there I just
owned stores businesses there so yeah
what else did you sell mops without
handles so I also own a Campus College
Davis College yeah so we actually
trained people to work in the Cannabis
industry so I trained almost all of
Arizona to work in the Cannabis industry
that was okay okay well let's do a
little role-playing exercise let's
pretend that Blanca is an HR she's about
to fire you but you have a solid
proposition with the new CBD business
try to sell her on your CBD business
it's just me talking yeah you just talk
she she's gonna fire you at the end of
it you're representing Shadow right now
in the CBD industry all the shadows and
all the shadows and CBD make them happy
and action I understand that uh this
company is not right for me and I'm not
right for this company but what I do
have is something really great for
that's right for everybody and that's
kind of cannibal and that is something
that can work with anybody's in
inocabinoid system and that is going to
help people feel better get more uh
sleep get more rest get more clarity in
their life I think we can work together
and work with the CBD industry and
create something new together what do
you think Dave I think that's something
yeah toxic work environment so it is
yeah you're fired Chad this is my last
line
my closing of babe
she just called you toxic
it is I try controlling that situation
that's awesome man you sell CBD
um what uh what's the craziest person
you sold CBD to everybody everybody who
comes in trying to get off medication is
[ __ ] insane so they're like all these
pills don't work for me anymore I need
something natural please help me sleep
please help me feel better
CBD and that's literally everybody who
came into our store it was just [ __ ]
needing something to have you ever told
them that maybe they could just smoke
weed
well see that's why I'm going out of
business that's why I'm here to be in a
comic because uh they can just smoke
weed yeah that is a thing yeah yeah yeah
all right and you do get CBD and weed
but you know high THC low CBD doesn't
make it no I I respect an underdog don't
worry all right yeah I mean she's
wearing uh whatever what's that Jersey
the pant North Carolina Panthers jersey
so she she was for underdogs too
what is the the company that you're
doing HR for
Wealth Management
oh wealth management wow was there a
sniper on you when I asked you that
question the fear in your eyes being
live streamed my full name was already
oh okay cool all right wealth management
yeah do you see a lot of CBD
entrepreneurs there
weird
careers hey trying comedy is often
nothing no yeah so so you're so you're a
lady what advice would you give to our
friend Shadow maybe the next random date
he goes on
um oh I don't know um
really no um uh
yeah let's
I'll start with one two left I don't I
didn't very nice
there you go I'm very sweet first off
first off losers
I know you're being nice but I come up
with 10 and the time is uh to say
something go ahead all right first off
lose the O second off if you're going
leather jacket don't do an undershirt
yeah oh
first off I'm here
[Music]
Shadow when people are talking try not
to talk over them
you're right
she definitely didn't pick this outfit
out right that was a thing
where's she at she's at home with the
kids man that's where I'm married yeah
it gets worse what the [ __ ] you think
yeah leave that broad with the kids
trying to get a date she's not here I
don't think HR is gonna [ __ ] with that
one
I think that's gonna be a Nick you look
like you're dressed to ride a moped
I did write a moped here no I did not I
did not I guess though I'm sorry we're
playing a little hard on you anything
that uh that you'd like to redeem
yourself with what's like the kind have
you donated to any Charities recently
I have not but I do I do adopt a lot of
dogs
great job dogs and we have dogs and then
what do you do with them at the end of
it we sacrifice them for Halloween
sacrifice for Halloween it's that's okay
yeah that's cool are you into dogs
Blanca Scorpio yeah
yeah what kind of dogs or do you have a
dog
live dogs me too they're a few of them
are alive
I'm not
I'm into dogs that are medium from there
yeah
Blanca do you have a dog uh no no not
anymore no oh what happened to it Shadow
got a hold of it
oh okay what kind of dog is it
yeah oh God yeah Shadow what what do you
have to say about that she has a shih
tzu what do you have any tips or tricks
for Shih Tzus just get them groomed keep
the hair out of their eyes
um in my room right now I don't know
what the [ __ ]
I have a racist dog is what I have
whoa where did he learn it from it's
adopted it's adopted but he's only
racist towards me he's cool with my
black friends
who are your friends
Shadow I you're killing it
this is her third worst date this month
really
is it is this not timing up to the other
ones
the worst worst ER one but this is it's
not the best what was the worst where or
one like
so that was fine and then that was the
final straw well no unfortunately no um
but then he was just drinking beers
while he drove me home
wait what oh yeah like like he was fun
time yeah and he was like you want
another one I was like I can't I haven't
been drinking beer this whole time so
yeah that's maybe the worst one in my
mind have you thought about maybe not
having a gluten allergy I've thought
about it yeah I know
all right it's not for everybody I get
it
uh what is it because I've been calling
you Blanco and Blanco or Blanca which is
it it's Blanca it's Blanca nice yeah for
is it is it white yes Spanish for white
yeah hell yeah yeah
you're not white but your name is yeah
all right cool Blanca the only Blanca I
know is Blanca giselda the street
fighter yeah sure no I thought it
I don't know I don't know I don't know
why I'm doing this word association with
your name
um but yeah that's cool uh Chad oh
shadow
do you have any advice for Blanca and
maybe
she could do better for her next date
I think uh being a single female in
Austin is pretty good for your next day
hell yeah yeah just be you be you yeah
and lock the doors tonight because don't
date married men even if it's better
than the guy before
yeah thank you
I'll give it up for Blanca and Shadow
they went on a date
I don't think they're gonna [ __ ]
let's get an lgbtqia plus member up here
if you signed up this could be you
I hope you're not too uh I hope you guys
are both lesbians or
gays because if you're a lesbian and a
gay you kind of broke the show
uh Jade Torres do we got a Jay Torres in
the house here she comes go on a date
with the lesbian Lexi
are you guys from the same table
should I pick another
I think you guys are the only lesbians
that signed up Alex v is Alex v a gay
man
well you want to go on a date with a
lesbian
why not
let's see this in action
[Applause]
all the way up the stairs
we got some Fourth Street action on 7th
Street tonight
a day with Jade
starting now
I am I'm very gay very very gay yes
awesome yes it's not a phase it's
definitely okay no I've always wanted to
go on a date with a lesbian so I'm glad
that we're here you know I've never been
on a date with a man so here we go okay
uh where are you from I'm from Laredo
how about yourself oh I'm from Austin
okay well Leander I claim Austin
what do you do I'm a therapist how about
you oh I'm a bartender perfect Bar menu
yes it's going great yeah
I've been here like six years okay how
about you uh my like I mean I moved away
it came back okay nice sorry I'm a
little nervous here with you know oh
crowded we don't know anybody yeah
that's fair
thank you thank you what do you do in
your free time I'd like to hang out with
my pup how about yourself oh I have a I
just got a puppy what kind of dog do you
have a little Mexican French Bulldog
I had an English bulldog okay what do
you have now I have a Jack Russell
terrier and a Blue Heeler he's a puppy
okay I'd have to Google with that
because I honestly yeah just like a very
smart athletic dog okay nice okay yes
nice and time give it up for these two
lgbtqia plus members
the chemistry was so much more there for
the people that are never gonna [ __ ]
[Laughter]
ing questions straight people be
tripping
what's the craziest are y'all was
straight
why don't you guess which one of us is
gay I'm gonna with like a presumption
yellow straight it's very unfortunate
you might be wrong about that watch your
words Dyke
he can say that I can say it I've sucked
enough [ __ ] to do it
I can't relate stuck in my car I also
have a dog
I'm gay and Dylan has a dog
is a great couple yeah yeah yeah that's
right yeah I know my radar was turning
on with getting over here
under what circumstances would you two
have sex
that's a no-go for me same no I should
hey is that stereotype true that uh gay
men and lesbians kind of like
they play body Knuckles together butt
heads um I've heard but from my
experience no like are you do you have
gay friends yes and do you have lesbian
friends yes all right well all right I
guess it's just me I've also bought a
hit because I'm some lesbian so there's
that it's been a little bit of both I
mean there's no common interests okay
there's no common interest like this guy
doesn't like the mountains and she both
like dogs though so I mean if you don't
like dogs it's a red flag yeah that is a
red flag
you'd never uh Park your Subaru and his
or put your moped and her Subaru
brag that brains huh what kind of cars
do gay people drive
I know the Subaru is for the lesbian I
don't drive a Subaru
also don't drive a Jeep well I don't
drive a rickshaw but it's still a
stereotype
[Music]
uh yeah you guys uh what's the craziest
thing that you've ever seen a straight
person do because we all know straight
people be tripping
that's a long list most recently most
recently
can I pass the question for
you maybe call himself straight and then
do things that aren't so straight oh
yeah yeah pretty common I told you not
to talk about that dude I would say I
agree
straight girl
straight and
hell yeah it's pretty cool seeing a lot
of videos like that
I'm sure you watched a lot
two five one two
it what
our straight brains are short-circuiting
right now we kind of don't know what to
say we're picturing this very sexy
scenario
um when's the last time that a straight
woman has hit on you
are you are you talking about your
friend right there no
no wait okay so are all of you lesbians
at that table unfortunately no
she's pregnant with a lesbian
that's called penetration
uh so yeah you guys how's the Austin uh
scene over here I mean I'm from Small
Town Texas I moved to Austin when I was
two and I love Austin I think it's
completely different from anywhere else
in Texas yeah
it's the best place yeah as as uh
meeting women out here not the best no
why not
um for my personal experience most
Austin lesbians have been with Austin
lesbians and I'm just not about that
scene yeah the side circles around yeah
there's not enough to go around it's
like a [ __ ] suit what I mean with
everybody from California you're moving
the selection is getting a little bit
better okay nice hopeful upgrading how
about the how about the guy scene not
great but better than Dorado I'll say
that much hell yeah awesome take that
one and put it on your chest we're
better than Laredo
do you have a harder time like when you
tell people that you're a therapist do
they you have a hard time starting
relationships because they know you can
psychoanalyze them
yeah I don't know it's been a while so I
can't really think of any references now
maybe because I'm on stage and whatnot
but probably not yeah oh well yeah I
didn't think you'd answer it like that
he's doing it right now
well would you like to uh play your hand
at trying to convert a straight
we got a bunch of straights and a bucket
here I feel like you might have a better
chance than me to be honest I love the
support but probably not
um okay screw it I'm already up here
yeah hell yeah who wants to see a sex
crime happen on stage no just kidding if
you don't want to come up you don't have
to but uh yeah do you have you have any
more questions for these two people
I think you guys are have a great
friendship coming up and you both have
dogs so just Teeter after that
and we love you
thank you guys
I don't know how to talk to people guys
that's how we end it okay dog life
uh Central I feel like there's not
enough straight females to go around and
we might make two straight dudes date
each other if we get bored
they give it up for a Jade and Alex v
[Applause]
we got a lot of straight dudes it's
rough in Austin huh I don't know what it
is but I have a harder time talking to
gay people
yeah all right first coming up we got
Annabelle Delgado Annabelle yeah
Delgado here she comes
oh we got Daniel tersei
Danny
Blanca's roommate
he's got the bluest balls in Austin
going on a date with Anna Annabelle
a lot of Latino latinx influence tonight
we'll give it away
and date in Espanol
tayden is fan I can't I can't do that
hey are you freezing I'm [ __ ] so cold
right now it is so cold in here yeah
I'm always cold so oh is that why you're
wearing a jacket right now
87 degrees that's a long sleeve shirt
all right
okay I'll take that houndstooth print I
like that that's good classy hey what's
your name again Daniel Daniel is what
the Asian people call me
which is a thing it's a thing yeah
so what do you do for a living uh I'm in
sales nice exactly what oh I sell
retirement funds to people oh fun yeah
my job doesn't offer the 401K so they
don't offer the 401K do they offer a
401k uh neither of them okay all right
what do you do for a living uh x-ray CT
Tech
x-rays yeah do you do with your eyes or
like you actually use a machine both
both
so you're like super well I got it and
time give it up for Daniel hey
I felt that really the weather thing
that was a great Icebreaker I really
felt that
thank you yeah really related being like
hey I get cold too it's [ __ ] cold are
you guys not cold are you guys I've
never been well not yet I guess I was
more talkative yeah because it's always
six inches deep into the nasty okay no
I'm freezing it is [ __ ] cold and it's
Daniel is cold
wait is that a long sleeve shirt
[Laughter]
no no I I you got to give some questions
you know for easy bad
I actually felt a lot of chemistry on
this one yeah I was horny I don't know I
don't know anyone else
Daniel is very hyper and you know oh my
God yeah and Annabelle's just playing it
cool you know relax she's like I don't
know all have health insurance
I'm poor
you could manage
that's good
that's great
um you uh yeah you're wearing the same
material that shadow was wearing it
seems like
um
rapist
yeah she's wearing a rapist this isn't a
Dahmer thing over there you look like
you're wearing one of those things that
they put on you to get an x-ray so you
don't radiate yourself oh makes sense
don't be mean to her she's very nice
well yeah I mean I don't want to calm
down someone's fat I'm wearing a shirt
with my own face on it so that's what it
was
criticize people's fashion
uh but yeah uh Annabelle you uh don't
have a 401k uh is there anything you
like to say to your employer Live on
YouTube right now
oh I actually love my employer okay
other than that yeah maybe uh take care
of your employees they actually do
that's the only thing okay
should join a union
figure that one out
Daniel what do you have to say to uh
Annabelle's employer
do they need to employ they don't get
you're do a retirement stuff and they
don't care this all turned to a job
interview yeah
[Music]
do you have any advice for Annabelle
get a 401k soon you look like you're
like 20 though so I don't know yeah I
don't 28. okay oh wow okay yeah that was
smooth yeah
that was smooth good job Daniel
with the Daniel it's more like a 401kk
is it because the camo is that the only
dance no just the racial episodes
like dating in Spanish I don't like it
wait do you know any Spanish Daniel not
really no a little bit but nothing that
would like like words I know words I
don't know how to put them together in a
sense
a lot of them are like bad words so
uh like Puta
nagas okay
oh yeah he's just describing his mother
right now
this is a Bad Bunny
do you like bad buddy
not bad
hey if you two were gonna go on a date
in real life what where would you take
her uh Mission office
ice
[Laughter]
she's laughing yeah uh
I don't know probably like a good spot
with like a drink like good drinks
cocktails that's usually what I go for
did you by chance go on a date with a
girl with a gluten allergy recently no
okay just wondering
do you uh can you drink beer Annabelle
are you okay Drinker okay A little dos
equis Yes actually there's a michelada
spot like right around the corner
yeah hell yeah what do you think about
that
hey hey go with the flow we get one
success story out of this let's do that
Margaritas are you both single yes I'm
single all right then you don't need us
and why not
anymore
uh okay you guys where would you want to
go on a first date because okay how
about second day if drinks are a first
date where would you want to go on a
second date
outside and don't know
outside walk paddle boarding I don't
know where do you know that's outside
that has paddle boarding walk
and beer and Bad Bunny too and drinks
and you've got 12 seconds
the river the
uh what do you think about that yeah
there's a green bell there's all sorts
of stuff you look like you live at
Zilker Park
you got a beautiful tan you got a
beautiful body great kneecaps too do you
want to go on a date hunt I do
hey Annabelle this is a two-part
question first part of the question
what's your favorite color second part
of the question what's the most painful
thing you've ever experienced in life
that's dark
um so favorite color I think black
most painful answers the next one too
sorry Daniel you're out of the picture
she's about to tell us a story about
something black that hurt her
you ever been like rock climbing or get
punched or
tattoo no I'm not that adventurous
actually snakes I just thought you were
goth for a little bit that's how that's
what I got from the first you thought I
was what I thought you were goth oh yeah
no
um painful Dylan's never seen a Mexican
person before they all have black hair
dude I live in Riverside
painful I'm still thinking
um no actually you don't have to say
that for the second day
green does that Vibe well with you no
not at all
for the darkness a little friction
that's needed
you're the light she's the dark
anything you've never experienced
something painful or you were uh door of
the exploring
no I got really bad blisters hiking
that's about it I don't know
Daniel have you uh ever got any blisters
yes rock climbing no
and how did the doctor treat it uh I got
a heavy dose of antibiotics hell yeah
clears it up you're back in Action yeah
wait two period cramps
period cramps there we go menstruation
yeah everyone on this stage knows a lot
about period cramps
we can all relate to that I do yes
I can sympathize I mean where does that
come from
Daniel let's just assume that you guys
are dating you guys have been in a
relationship and Annabelle comes to you
she's like I got a really bad period
cramps how would you empathize with her
and make her feel better
uh suck it up
Daniel uh actually uh I I would actually
and not trying to plug CBD I would I
would say you should try Edibles Shadow
is this your business associate you plug
them in here yeah no I I actually grew
up with a single mom and uh she dealt
with that and she would do Edibles so I
always offer that as like if they've
never tried it that's not surprising
that your mom was a pothead yeah I I run
to the family okay no actually I don't
really smoke weed no way you totally
built for it dude
you're wearing the uniform
uh Annabelle how's what uh what kind of
company do you work for
I work in a freestanding ER and at the
hospital part-time
what what did she say a freestanding ER
freestanding ER yes it's like a tent
that you treat people
lives
kind of I guess I'm not a nurse so
oh right x-rays that's dope you ever see
something in there that you're like whoa
that's I should be in there drugs
so you can see you can see if people
have done drugs with an x-ray uh you
could see like the baggies up there
oh that kind of actually nice
so you're fishing for balloons in some
people yeah
she's standing in ER do you work for the
cartel
I don't
know I'd be I wouldn't be here I'd be
somewhere at the beach or something yeah
why would you want to be in Austin the
best city in the world
um that's cool so you see people they're
like oh I got a stomachache and also I
happen to have swallowed drugs about two
days ago like they can't put two and two
together themselves
I'm not gonna tell you that you have
drugs
Dane what do you do again
sales sales well what do you sell yeah I
specifically I sell IRAs so individual
retirement plans yeah retirement plans
thanks Hans uh does that does that yield
a lot of money uh it can not in the
market we're in right now okay yeah you
may have to support him
I'm okay with that
wow
[Music]
feminism
don't let her go you idiot
never hurt her yeah don't group me with
her you idiot he's just gonna roommate
with all the hottest girls in Austin so
you [ __ ] up your [ __ ] again and ask her
to live with you
platonically you [ __ ] idiot you
really haunt you want to split rent with
me
oh babe and it would be great if we both
got on a lease
foreign
Daniel you might have to swallow some
drugs and cross the border
this retirement thing doesn't work out
okay yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah Dylan
jarbo you have anything to say to these
people I really think you where are you
guys gonna go around the corner uh the
michelada spot hey let's set up a table
go over there and we can discuss
retirement together Dylan's inviting
himself
I really don't have one either so I
might pencil in on the same time but you
guys look cute together look at him look
how cute they are together look at that
they're not sitting close to each other
but
great times to get this we there's not a
lot of sex like great couples that come
out of here
well don't say that well don't insult
the show I'm not gonna insult the show
but I think we have one right here guys
we got a live one I feel like you keep
looking at my legs when you say that I'm
sorry I'm waiting for them to touch each
other but sorry Blanca you're gonna have
to find a new roommate
well give it up for this couple
Annabelle and Daniel
they're a beautiful couple
I'm rooting for those two
those are good ones can I pick one
oh oh you watch that okay no no we'll do
it for real no no Dylan it's all about
you okay this person has an instruction
on how to say her name she's a type A
give it up for party
it's Paris the most eligible bachelor
out there
Jimmy Clifford Jimmy
Jimmy Clifford fan favorite
Jimmy C going on a date with Paris
like Marie with a p
IC so your name is Paris
yes it's a French name okay nice to meet
you I'm Jimmy where are you from Bree do
you see do you see like actually DC or
outside okay DMV
there you go I'm from Jersey oh which
part Jersey Shore
oh that's fun so clean so clean that's
nice parts of it are I mean you go down
to Seaside I wouldn't exactly throw the
word clean around you know it's pretty
gross yeah
so the first straight guy was married
what's your backstory I am not married
I'm single I thought that was a
prerequisite for the show but apparently
not
the dating shows like oh hey honey I
I'll be back I'm going out to the dating
show don't wait up
so so uh how old are you I'm 25. I'm
close to that what do you do for a
living uh
Hey listen it's not that you're in the
car it's the miles right uh I work at a
bar very close to here
which one and time give it up for the
secret of Jimmy Clifford I should have
said your full name and Paris a French
name it's also a French city it is one
of the most popular French cities how
did you uh get the name Pari
oh [ __ ] tell it
I was supposed to be a boy and then um
my mother traded land to have me named
after my godmother
what
she got free land if she named her after
named me after my godmother so you're
named the way you are because your mom
wanted to land yes
yeah yeah the woman that sold her
daughter's name from Land what happened
to this land is there a McDonald's on it
now she still lives on it you're still
living on it you still got the daughter
yeah wow
that's awesome so why was your name
leveraged on the fact of whether or not
your your mom would get land
[Laughter]
you have a name so uh her friend was
like if you name her after me you can
have this land so she was like sure are
you gonna get that Land one day
I mean she's gonna die eventually so
maybe
she didn't know that yeah I'm gonna
update her well after this spoiler alert
wait who caused your mom more problems
the land or you growing up I was a
lovely child so I guess the land okay I
mean I'm a school teacher so I'm quite
what grade
Middle School my sister teaches fourth
grade in DC
yeah a good brother would know I don't
know
how close is the magic happening I feel
I feel like yeah yeah no I I feel like I
think it's going well I mean
maybe just like ends in sex but you know
they're doing pretty well I don't know
if you guys have sex I don't know you
have plenty of land to do it on
if you both have a child and I give you
these nicotine pouches
will you name it Dylan from lights out
with David Spade yeah
that's how they do it in your family
apparently
Jimmy you're unmarried unmarried you're
from Jersey Shore yeah Paris was trying
to be like oh that's nice they're like
no no she was giving
it nice
all of it's nice but I think most of the
world knows your area from that TV show
here's the thing that TV show dead on
that's what's there
some of it's nice you know I mean you
know yeah Snooki has a Vibe tour yeah
there's sidewalks
they're like cocaine listen uh you know
one man's hooker is another man's wife
so um
it's quite the pickup line where where
did you grow up again I'm I'm from
Virginia but I lived in New Jersey for
five years oh okay it's like chlamydia
of states where where you've never been
to Florida have you no I have yeah
that's like the gonorrhea station yeah
and uh giving or receiving
[Laughter]
that's funny he's a funny guy
Jimmy we can't take it
well okay where would you two go on a
date Jimmy
well you've seen very classic so I think
dinner would be good start I would go
like typically if we were in Jersey I'd
go Italian but there's dog [ __ ] Italian
here in Austin so I think we go like
maybe a Mexican Fusion maybe outdoor
it's a good place yeah like eight eight
o'clock nice little dusk come here set
the mood you like dusk
sure hell yeah oh
what the [ __ ] is up with the bats here
they never come out that's the fusion
that's
it they come out of that Dusky the bats
they come out no they don't that's a lie
Jersey
all right here we go at least we have
bats take me to a bridge where they're
actually bats that's where we're on our
first date okay second date's Chipotle
she's from Virginia that's like TGI
Fridays over there
that's fair I'm affordable I think what
kind of music do you like
so I pretend like I know like hot cross
buns I'm like oh yeah Bad Bunny is so
like dope kids is it I
oh would you say it's lit would you say
you know Spanish Poco
oh so they don't they're just listening
off the walls huh
so when I hear words like like the Punta
I pretend like I don't know Punta yeah
what does that mean that means B puta
it's puta yeah
like they're like oh you're a punta and
like oh that means respect there's no oh
they yelling at you huta
close she is from are you in like a
freedom writer situation
okay
I was just curious would you name your
child Snooki to get some land on the
Jersey Shore
that's pricey land that is pricey
sealant well then again snooky's a
horrible name now
Snooki is and you have to get like the
hairspray for the bang
yeah get it like the full effect Jimmy
would you take her to the [ __ ] Harbor
though was that a Jersey accent sure
Jersey Shore it's down the shore we'll
see the water yeah water hey how long
has was the last relationship for both
of you how how long per each uh about
two years two years
18
18. so like longer than he's been alive
I think OH Close yeah he's 18 years old
what would you do with this shiny new
penny where would you put him
well he's so young so all sorts of
things he's so limber like all cartilage
this one
like a shark
baby shark
I can be a part of her class
you could be your Show and Tell item
yeah
what what would you teach Jimmy because
if you're a teacher if you had to teach
him a song
thank you for the person that said that
it's a wonderful style I knew you and me
best lady we're right there we're right
don't you think Jimmy
don't you think that Jimmy would kind of
be a problem child he'd get a detention
a lot and you'd have to discipline him
that seems like like the front for Like
a Porn but like maybe exactly
let's let's just set up a role-playing
situation
so there I was teaching a class she
thought about this bad boy
is that the scenario or this has been
written down in a journal somewhere oh
no I forgot my homework again
well you need to be
after school
my mom's picking me up at four though so
I don't
keep bringing a minivan
she's trying to get a threesome started
with your mom my mother
yeah it was put up the divider you know
take us to soccer practice
is it my practice are we just going to
expose ourselves in front of children
hang out the soccer
parade you're wearing a shirt that says
mother of dragons yeah well I mean like
I have kids it's not like a friend for
cats or anything
so what kind of dragons do you have
children like human
human dragons yeah yeah
are they like whites call their children
we call them dragons
a father figure
Jimmy do your best impression of being a
dad uh
um
I noticed you're not mowing the lawn
because they don't they don't even yell
at you they just walk in and they just
say what you're not doing like oh you're
sitting on the couch not doing the
dishes though
just like really Petty they're like who
is this guy he's like three years older
than me
wrong
I'm not judging
they're Jersey folks you go get some
pasta okay good how old are your
children
[Music]
eight and thirteen boy girl
okay are you sure she's figure it out
yeah she know it the people that you
love their ages and genders it's a real
quiz you got to think about that they
know that's all all that matters I hope
so I think you should be nowadays I
don't know I don't think they know their
genders all that well they're switching
it up all the time
Jimmy how's your uh gender are you uh
how's my gender that's pretty good last
I checked at least have you ever uh been
down to Fourth Street I have been Fourth
Street yes gone into frogs or uh
whatever it's called I've been to a
couple of the spots I don't know about
frogs but I don't think that's a place I
think that's in Atlanta what uh are you
you're straight As [ __ ] you've never
done anything gave it before
I mean I don't you know they say uh [ __ ]
he's gay I'm pretty I'm straight I think
I've asked myself there's about three
men in the world that I would go gay for
no question
Dylan
never gonna happen
no I go um Tom Brady 100 we're never I
mean he's a champion he's a Champion
number two Enrique Iglesias
that dude's sexy as [ __ ] and that's just
objectively right these are the sexiest
[ __ ] these are the sexiest men from
1999. and the third one the third one is
uh the guy his name's Tom Ellis he plays
Lucifer on Netflix oh nice he's British
he's like just [ __ ] cool and I don't
know I think I would like that because
we would all just get to hang out like I
would we would have sex and stuff but I
would more just be like oh dude let's
[ __ ] kick it you know just don't look
him in the eyes yeah I mean everyone
does pinching pinching in college
pinching yeah I did I did a little pinch
sucker
my table parade have you ever done
anything lesbian like
pinching
it sounds like a third guy is just
joining and I don't really want one guy
let alone two
one that's true that's why I uh
do you want to have sex with me hey
[Music]
uh well you can meet her too Dylan yeah
does she want to have sex what the [ __ ]
yeah I don't care if People's bombs are
here what am I five
[Laughter]
she's her own person does she have a
minivan where the seats go down
my mom will pick you up when your mom
drops me off
pray you're you're in good spirits you
know you're a good uh you have a good
sense of humor
um
hell yeah what were you doing before
this were you were you out on the town
uh well no I took a power nap and then
then I drank a lot and now I'm here
hell yeah power nap meeting my future
[Music]
bow boy toy yeah boy toy
what would you guys go together uh
daycare
I mean I wouldn't bring her to a daycare
I feel like that would set a weird vibe
it would be weird
have you guys ever been to Chili's you
guys look like a Chili yeah dude I'm
more of an Applebee's guy if I'm being
honest oh man you know high priced apps
dude count me in I mean I think you're
wrong but you know what I think you two
at Applebee's would be really cute yeah
the two straws with the one check I got
you hell yeah yeah of course she's pain
you guys ever heard of a two for 20 yes
and I do mean the sexual kind
all right here we go
so what what happened with the uh
relationship that you were in for 18
years how did that end
I mean not with murder which would have
been ideal he's still alive somewhere
but yeah what a Pity love a feisty woman
you never know Jimmy your first task as
a boyfriend is to murder her ex but her
seven evil ex-boyfriends
take me a picture how would I murder
your ex
actly
hey Mom I need some help over here
yeah I got back up okay she's got plenty
of trunk space in that minivan
so resourceful he is yeah it's Jersey
how would you do it Jimmy how would I
murder a man well I don't know this guy
so no one's going to be looking to me
right you're a stick
side no no I'm saying no one's going to
expect some schmuck from Jersey murdered
this guy only only all of us would know
and we all swear not to touch okay
um
how would I don't know I guess to cut
the brakes on the car
drivers
oh well well
better than Uber drivers I love it so
you know where the brakes are you get
under there
wow
we're playing a murder together I think
this is all really good yeah the wheels
are turning her head right now
I mean the last couple I feel like
really
really there you go that's how you build
exactly put some Stakes on that you know
it's raw that's right oh cool well give
it up for Jimmy and Paris
they went on a date
[Applause]
that was cute it's like a mother
Sundance
we got another couple coming up we got
two more females left
we gotta use them sparingly
oh this is the same Pierre
oh my God I think we ran out of females
[Music]
perini's uh typical Austin right
yeah you put her name in three times
hey Hans I got a wild idea what what if
we do uh Pierre's Mom and Dad hey who
wants to see his mom and dad go on a
date
yeah come on the crowd has spoken
we're gonna watch a woman who sold her
daughter's name for a piece of land
go on a date with her husband who was
okay with that
[Applause]
mother and father
going on a date after they heard that
their daughter did some lesbian
activities in college
spicy
uh what was your name
Liz going on a date with
Rick Liz and Rick give it up for Liz and
Rick ladies and gentlemen
one minute starting now
what color of underwear do you have on
you want to do some tequila shots
how many
you buying until I my credit card says
no more
oh never mind because your money's
actually my money so nowhere
no more thoughts so we'll just pretend
to do some water yeah date's over sorry
about that
I gotta say you can't see them at my
angle but I am very hard
this is this is everything everyone said
this is what you want right here how
would you guys y'all been uh married for
um we've been dating for 15 years dating
for 15. no ring no ring wow Rick Texas
style huh
that's great where'd y'all meet
uh in Virginia Virginia very nice do you
remember the first day and time oh
absolutely what happened no sex
did you change your oil that's how you
remember it huh that's great did you get
to spend the day together yeah would you
guys kiss for the first time you
remember that that night that night yeah
where at what was it what would it feel
like on Yeah well yeah besides that like
we looked up would you what made you go
for it it was the end of the night so it
was yeah so it's about time right
we thought I was a hooker and I had to
go to my next date oh no your daughter
no wait he thought you were a hooker
well
I had another
you already made sure he was gonna
because I'm a claim her for mine right
now wow so we made plans for the next
day
right now kept his foot in line yeah
that's how you do it that's how you do
it what year was this
this was in 08 yeah okay wow right right
right during the recession great job
putting your foot right there great time
what was the second date like
what'd y'all do we went to uh the
racetrack horse races
okay
have any mint Mojitos any juleps
yeah who knows we're old we can't
remember that far back and when was was
that the night the sex happened yeah it
was a couple of nights later okay what a
gentleman you are great work you held
into there huh it was like the fourth
date I mean I'm old school well there is
no dane as bad yeah no other thing to do
and then just come back right and just
keep going for it I'm attractive because
he had a job and a heartbeat
good quality way to go Rick yeah anymore
hey you still got a heartbeat so we're
working with that yeah trying to move in
on that land money I know what you mean
it's available hell yeah all right cool
yeah what are we doing to keep like the
relationship going with you guys
what's tequila tequila there we go I
think naked Fridays
naked Fridays is that a real thing yeah
you wouldn't even get off work on
Fridays I'd green with the door and we'd
do uh the killer shots and be naked oh
hell yeah oh damn for naked Fridays her
kids don't want to hear she says she
says he comes to the door I'm ready I'm
naked we do tequila shots and the rest
is I think we can imagine it right now
that's hot and you guys have been doing
that for a long time
that's a long time
now we're in an RV park with a bunch of
other people
55 and older
older and you're out [ __ ] them all I
can tell I'd say it did naked Friday's
catch on in the RV park it's very
popular yeah oh yeah RV's rocking don't
come talking about it
unless you're on a podcast it's not a
pretty sight it's over 55. that's what
we take our glasses off
that's a tequila too they give you a
little money okay take the hearing aids
out also what'd you say
he's been around the block newest kill
Tony regular rig
and replaced me
that's hot so if you guys are apart do
you guys still celebrate from afar just
zoom it in
do a little face time
you know we really never spent that much
time apart
we can't we don't have to work our phone
that way really you know it jams up and
you know it jams up
are you talking about your printer
calling somebody in Austin's one of the
kids and they're saying mom why wear
your clothes you know wrong name
you tell her it's Friday get back good
Fridays that's how we do it seven days a
week
Friday seven days a week we're gonna
extend this to an all weekend naked
holiday hey so you two have been
together for 15 years now what's the key
to a good relationship
he pays I enjoy
please there's only three rules three
rules I'm always wrong I always pay c
one and two above hey good man Rick a
naked Friday good Fridays that's how you
get the naked Fridays one two three
[Laughter]
you don't get naked Fridays if you don't
follow one two and three
so what's the biggest argument you guys
have been in
whether or not to come to this show
tonight
did you lose I lost it
right I wanted to Uber but they said Mom
you gotta walk
so you know I said fine we'll walk it's
okay at least they didn't make your bird
scooter that's what the kids are doing
these days
take a bird scooter and vape over here
have you guys been in Austin a long time
uh Paris birthday no
no oh your other sister
oh the favorite one
yo Paris you better be getting that
[ __ ] land
me
she's my favorite living up to your
glory right now
damn [ __ ]
what did you get when you had her a car
well no I've named her after me so
nothing yeah obviously she's Liz
Ard
the gift that keeps on giving
you
had her and you're like let's have more
of these
what's something sexually you both have
never tried and are going to try tonight
foreign
[Music]
what did you get with this guy a pack of
beer
this guy's [ __ ]
say there's nothing that we haven't
tried oh that's what I like to hear
I'm gonna live up to right there
give it up for the couple that invented
eating ass
oh there's nothing you ever done that
[ __ ] what 2008 that's what you guys
met
yeah but I'm 70 so there's a lot of
experience yeah been working at it every
day
hey
I think we're all working at it right
now
that's good that's great so uh what are
you guys gonna do uh for the rest of the
trip here tonight
you guys gonna go to you know maybe uh
michelada spa or whatever Margarita spot
Michaela tequila there we go we're we're
living the first night right
only five days till Friday
only two days since the last Friday oh
[ __ ]
[Applause]
he's got to start taking that Viagra now
to get ready for Friday I don't know if
you two need to hear this but I'm gonna
be thinking about you for a long time
take a picture
I already did the retirement guy already
left yeah give it up for Liz and Rick
the ogs
that was beautiful the experts
[Applause]
I cannot stop picturing that RVs rocking
tonight y'all
cannot stop picturing the color of her
panties
uh any woman want to come up and go on a
date with a mystery man come on maybe
Lexi is that your name
sure here she comes Lexi
[Music]
going on a date with Jose
to the main stage
here he comes Jose going on a date
ladies first what a gentleman
Jose
going today with Lexi
here they go starting now
hello hello hi what's your name again
Lexi Lexi who was that show for like
Alex short for Alexa Alexa cool okay my
name is Jose
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
where are you from I'm from Peru
it's never been never been never school
it's a good place a good place nice nice
yeah I'm from
cool cool so how old are you well sorry
I'm sorry it's okay I'm 24. oh yeah yeah
it's all right it's a good they're gonna
ask you your age if you're under 25 so
that's good
[Music]
33 okay
yeah that's it we love it love it um so
what do you do for work I am an
Amina cool about you
um I own my own company okay coffee
business coffee business here or in Peru
in Peru coffee
just just Peruvian coffee is always
people usually go Peruvian coffee sure
and I'm like no it's it's really coffee
and time relax Jose this isn't a customs
office
you never know you never know who's
watching Hans I mean you know you've got
to cross borders probably good point
arresting boys we got him uh Lexi
welcome to the show thanks you signed up
for the lgbtqia plus bucket totally
are you excited to be on a day with a
man wow that's kind of rare so excited
yeah well they're not a diamond do you
uh do you go both ways
sometimes all right sometimes is enough
you know what I mean all right
sometimes it's more than one time so
yeah definitely and sometimes Jose
actually sells coffee yes
sometimes yeah what was the last date
you went on with a man
there's never been a date
it's just straight [ __ ]
correct oh really so are you one of
those like that you get on Tinder and
then you just put like 1K and then you
swipe anything you like and then someone
says hey what's up and then you're like
yep
um have you done that like the just the
Tinder thing no they were just work
friends oh
never tender oh right work friends
that's good hunt close to home
what uh what's the craziest thing that's
happened with a work friend of yours
we had sex after a corporate party
was it on a naked Friday
no it was a Wednesday
you had sex on a Wednesday hump day on a
school night
sex wow that's freaky hopefully not her
school night yeah
just signed you know Jose how long have
you been in the states
uh I arrived last week
last week are you just uh visiting are
you living here now um visiting so I'm
just I live in Peru and I come back and
forth so so basically you know you could
uh
it seems like a scenario where you're
never going to see this person for long
after if anything happened you wouldn't
have to worry yeah like no strings
attached and like work you know yeah you
know what they say Sunday is the new
Wednesday
I mean yeah
and I literally just shaved the beard so
he's ready for action he left the
mustache for this year uh Lexi right
Lexi have you ever been afforded the
Protection Services of a cartel
and is that something that interests you
oh
God
pretty safe
all right Jose have you ever swallowed
little baggies of drugs and got an x-ray
at a makeshift tent
Hans
um look all life is if I say yes because
I haven't but I I'm looking to
experience experiment a lot of different
things in this trip so you know that's
okay well I'm going to tread carefully
because I don't want you to kill me with
a cattle prod or whatever from No
Country for Old Men I'm kind of down
with it
how long are you here on business uh
technically no I'm here just this is a
holiday business was uh before came here
so yeah this is just so I gotta know
uh you say coffee and then you wink a
lot what does that mean uh I'll go
Tourette's yeah okay
coffee good and do you sell coffee to
say comedians yeah all the time all the
time how much for an eight ball of
coffee yeah here well able to Able it
comes in different sizes but you know we
we try to make it just concise with
everything we explored in the country so
you know we want to make sure that you
guys understand Apple of coffee Apple
Coke easy yeah fantastic well we should
talk after the show Absolutely I'll give
you my business card actually I have
some coffee in my hostel
Tourette's again sorry
a hard time explaining that to customs
please this is a comedy show right
hush is the name of the coffee you don't
understand
Annabelle has left the building she does
not want to get arrested with you Jose
hey hey
Jade
uh do you have any history
yes yeah correct all right I've got a
question could I ask a question yeah
yeah so
um you go both ways right
not normally not normally but you have
correct all right so
um do you miss flesh
what is it different
because I mean like you know guys we've
got something that hangs that is made
out of skin fresh skin right well sorry
my my English is English is not my first
language Hans this is the Peruvian
Jeffrey Dahmer
he wants to make a lampshade I just want
to understand if people just feel you
remember how the flesh feels
don't you do you remember the flesh
yeah that sounds pretty bad sorry
better with girls all
yeah I know I'm I'm with you
you agree on that you both think sex
with women is better much better 100 100
yeah and I've tried it I agree with
Paris oh she's gone
yeah you know you gotta try it you got
to try it both ways so you have history
with uh Jade
and uh how how's what kind of History
how many Wednesdays have you been going
out
uh
70 Wednesdays she was my My First
Girlfriend 10 years ago
wow
when did y'all reconnect
six weeks ago how's that going great we
bring both of them up here yeah
we'd like to do that again we did I
think it would be yeah yeah we should do
that Jose would you like to uh say we
love you man thank you go get the coffee
ready great stash you're welcome start
brewing a real love going on shut the
[ __ ] up give it up for Jose okay we love
you man but
there she comes Jade
from 10 years ago
reuniting a blast from the past for Lexi
she's gonna rekindle just tell her what
you've been doing they're beautiful
relationships it's been great
all right let's start the minute now
we're gonna
we're gonna starting
where are you from
don't do that [ __ ] she's from St Louis
earlier she said she was from Austin she
was lying she's from St Louis I'm from
Austin
she likes to claim Austin
um what do you do in your free time
hang out with you oh what do you what do
you like to do I mean I know what we do
but I don't know if you like that
anymore
you know what I mean no
I mean things change in 10 years I mean
so what do you like to do in your free
time I like to hang out with my dog
Penny what kind of dog is she she's a
boxer how old is she she's five okay
what about you what do you like to do
um I like to go I like to go to any
Austin FC game you know any Austin
Athletics I really like sports I'm a big
Sports fanatic
same cool what's your drink of choice
um a margarita with salt okay what kind
of tequila you like and Thyme give it up
for the two Beautiful Lovers
well I know who tops
10 years is a lot of time [ __ ] changes
you know
I'm different now this Little Shelter
truck you start [ __ ] [ __ ] in Texas
you end up sounding like Matthew
McConaughey no matter what generally you
guys you get the Twang and the little
the the whistle in the S you've got it
yeah are you talking about eating [ __ ]
right now do you want to talk about it
and give you a lot of pointers wow yeah
what can you can you give me a couple
pointers
is number one
do you have a tongue ring I don't know
what you're talking about she does do
you have a tongue ring I can't relate if
you can see
you probably can't Jade is hiding her
tongue ring but Lexi is really really
yeah that's what you're talking about
that's good oh yeah Lexi is she
definitely has her tongue ring right I I
don't know we're gonna need a cleanup on
aisle four if you know what I mean Lexi
is he's getting wet over here on a
Wednesday
so uh Lexi what's your favorite uh
favorite thing about like when Jade goes
down on you besides the tongue ring
uh
back in 2012 or
is it 10 years ago
um
if you have a tongue ring it speeds up
the process for the other person that's
all I can say
okay where is the bean located you don't
know no how old are you I'm a 28. how
many sexual partners have you had uh
they don't have beans if you know what I
mean gotcha yeah I don't know where the
G-Spot is either so like we can we can
how important is the bean this is a
question for all the ladies
okay important all right I want to know
do we have the Sailor hats we can give
them
all right we've got a couple of Sailor
hats for you ladies after the show
just put paint a circle around it so we
can see it next so it was 10 years when
you guys first met where where'd y'all
meet and how did how did it start up oh
it's very stereotypical we were playing
oh my God what positions I was in the
Outfield I'm pretty sure she was the
catcher at the time yeah
[Laughter]
she was straight you know you know how
it goes yeah yeah I do and the whole
parent's not agreeing the whole
stereotype she threw a little underhand
pitch up there the rest is history
that's beautiful how long did y'all date
I would say
three years
wow
for about three years
did not talk for we'll say seven to
eight wow so what what who messed up
who brought in the pinch hitter
[Laughter]
and how big was this bat
her bats
oh under the Congress bridge but enough
time has passed you you all seem like
y'all have gotten past it right oh we
had a we had a good connection from the
beginning so it wasn't it wasn't much
that's great that's great there's a
connection you can't deny you knew how
to yeah hell yeah that's called a tongue
ring that's right it's the time invest
invest in it it's lost static
feeling it you guys think about getting
the team back together
they've been back together it's a work
in progress you think about just just
spit like getting it going again here
soon it's been going already for six
weeks and then it's been a lot of
awkward energy since then or has we just
straight professional all time no it's
been great
we have a connection
we can all feel it connected tongue the
[ __ ]
you can't deny it
do you are you
oh so many questions yeah yeah yeah no
don't hold that bring it on no I I'm
just getting over the bean thing but
I can help you did you uh do you do the
the strap-on thing
I don't need it
yeah that's why I'm hey give me a little
action on that [ __ ] how big is this
tongue ring
how are you talking right now it's on a
need to know basis
I mean
do you ever return the favor
it wouldn't be a relationship if it
wasn't two ways yeah
they know they know the same that old
couple the RV couple knows the same [ __ ]
it all goes around Circle here
well this is fascinating
yeah yeah I feel like all the straight
guys [ __ ] get get your rocks off yeah
look at that sorry someone did that
Dylan are you high what the [ __ ] are you
saying no I'm high off romance right now
I've seen this and this and this I just
feel so alone right now but they you
know would you two ever sleep with Dylan
just for one night off me personally no
you have nothing to offer me
throw me in the rotation we we get you
all in a softball field with a couple
equipment and we just see what happens
that's a different ball game hey put me
in the seventh inning we'll figure it
out after that
some of that over here
Lexi uh what's your favorite thing about
the the relationship that you have now
like besides the tongue ring
people equally yeah that's awesome okay
super games super gay
unless you're Dylan jarbo in which case
you have nothing to offer her
got a solid change up tell you that put
me on the field Dylan you know a lot
about sports
I'm just glad hey I'm glad you guys got
together here and to reconnect you
already playing together but you think
anything could come out of this
we're working on it it's a working
program what's your favorite thing about
Lexi she's my best friend I can tell her
anything she accepts me for accepts me
for who I am there's I don't have to lie
to her I have to hide anything from her
it's completely genuine and you know
where that beans at yeah
give it up for Lexi
Jay
successful
cut here so far
what a what a chivalrous gesture that
was
they're taking care of each other
they're catching and throwing softballs
with each other all night long yeah
that's right keeping it infield keeping
it Outfield
these ladies are going to bring home the
championship I can feel them
that was a show give it up for all the
people that you saw tonight
anything you guys want to plug
uh nothing but there was a lot of Love
Tonight guys keep that energy up a lot
of beautiful romantic they're they're
gonna kill it tonight but uh
Barstool Sports over here and he's got
all the cliches lined up
uh Dylan jarbo check him out uh Dylan
Sullivan any uh any lasting words of
wisdom uh you know what just uh just
follow your heart and always keep that
land in mind there you go looking
forward to naked Fridays everybody
thanks Hans that was a show thank you
guys so much have a good night
[Applause]
[Music]